bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 78 sport tout de suite on
passe au sommaire box coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur la team farouja basé à
il en cours l'équipe a sortie des
dizaines de champions nous allons
essayer de décrypter cette réussite avec
l'entraîneur Tangi farouja le coach sera
accompagné des boxeurs Marvin petit
Gabriel avnel handbal la team 78 a
terminé 2e de son tournoi ce weekend une
compétition qui était organisée à
Versailles etlancour et morpa tous les
détails sont à suivre dans ce magazine
tennis les y Lig compte près de 45000
licenciés nous feront le point sur
l'engouement pour ce sport dans le
département interview à suit avec le
président de la ligue des ivil Norbert
rampola et puis en fin d'émission vous
retrouverez tous les résultats sportifs
du weekend dans le
département c'est sûrement l'un des
meilleurs clubs de boxe en France la
team farouja Basel est en cours à sortie
des dizaines de champions de France des
champions d'Europe et des champions du
monde pour parler de ce club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le coach Tangi
farouja bonsoir Marvin petit boxeur dans
la catégorie poids léger et Gabriel
avnel demi-finaliste France en amateur
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir Tangi est-ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler l'histoire
donc de la team farouja le club s'est
créé en
98 on était à Montini Bretonneux et mon
père était à Levalois Péré à l'époque et
on a décidé de faire un club en commun
euh en en 98 la maie des lancours nous a
donné l'accord et nous a suivi du moins
les premières années pour pour bien
monter le club et quel boxeur la team
farouja a formé beaucoup
beaucoupoup monde beaucoup de monde
voilà il y en a un qui sort de chez nous
qui actuellement qui s'appelle almedel
Moussaoui il y a petits gens il y a il y
a humormec il y a eu faouszi à table
Valéri Kayumba qui était champion d'OPE
tout ça c'était des gens qui ont été
champions d'urope champion du monde
après voilà Marvin petit adilam mouadi
pour les présents et d'autres qui
arrivent encore comme comme B qui a pas
pu venir ce soir voilà batrice Mendy
batrice Mendy voilà et qu'est-ce qui
fait la force de cette team farouja
justement Marvin petit c'est de
s'entraîner dur quoi c'est
l'entraînement qui est on a un bon
entraînement et le coach est toujours
derrière nous quoi et est-ce qu'il y a
un esprit team farouja oui un esprit
c'est c'est familial quoi et est-ce que
c'est un club qui pe vous faire
progresser oui exactement c'est un c'est
un club où j'ai j'ai été j'ai commencé
dedans et maintenant je je finirai ma
carrière de avec tangy faroua quoi
pareil pour vous Gabriel avnel c'est un
club qui peut faire progresser c'est un
club qui m'a fait progresser sur tous
les points tant sur le plan
psychologique que sur le plan sportif
quand vous m'ariez vu arriver quand je
suis arrivé à la salle il y a quelques
années j'avais je pense que personne
pouvait dire que j'allais finir boxeur
professionnel et pour moi ça c'est un
rêve qui qui était qui était
irréalisable et Tangui a pu le réaliser
alors non seulement Tangi mais c'est
aussi avec l'aide de Marvin qui qui m'a
énormément aidé avant tout la team Foria
pour moi c'est c'est comme son l'indique
c'est une équipe c'est une famille et
c'est grâce à ça qu'on avance on est une
famille et quelle est l'ambiance
justement dans dans ce club toujours bon
enfant on rigole on s'amuse même que ça
soit à la salle ou en dehors on
plaisante lorsqu'on part en déplacement
c'est c'est comme si on partait en
famille tout simplement marvine petit ça
tire peut-être les autres vers le haut
justement oui exactement c'est Comé dit
c'est c'est une famille on est toujours
en train de rigoler on est en train de
se charer un petit peu quoi toujours en
train de rigoler entre nous quoi et donc
il y a également la la relève qui arrive
avec Béatrice mend on l'a évoqué
brièvement tout à l'heure donc elle
vient d'être sacrée championne de France
cadette est-ce qu'elle le mérite tout
simplement mérite on devient pas
champion de France comme ça surtout que
personne l'attendait donc oui c'est le
mérite mais si c'est possible je fais
une petite parenthèse sur Gabriel qui
est passé pro en 2 ans voilà je fais une
petite qui est passé qui était qui était
champion d'Île de France la première
année qui boxait et voilà et et un bon
parcours en peu de temps et donc voilà
il y a Gabriel avnel est-ce que c'est la
relève finalement la team farouer oui il
é il a même fait quelques combats
internationaux ouais la relève il y en
il y en a d'autres il y a Rachid aschoui
qui monte il a il y a si pro dans la
salle et ils sont tous sortis de de la
team on va dire voilà donc voilà après
il y en a d'autres qui partent parce que
côté business se sent mieux mais il
regrettent le côté cœur qui a en cours
et donc l'équipe donc est composé
essentiellement quand même de de
professionnel quand même enfin des
boxeurs qui veulent le devenir en tout
cas vous sélectionner comment ces
boxeurs le
cœur j' dirais pas plus le cœur après le
cœur qui met à l'entraînement le cœur
qu' a aussi à côté de de à côté du ring
et voilà c'est ça que je moi c'est
làdessus que je repère vous regardez
peut-être certains crites aussi
technique aussi non pas du tout vous
avez vu comme il vous a dit Gabriel
quand il est
arrivé il avait 15 ans il faisait
combien tu faisais 90 95 90 kg voilà 90
kg avec les Chud de Michael Jackson et
et et comment on appelle ça et vous avez
vu ça c'était
vous aurez pas misé un centime dessus
aujourd'hui tout le monde dit voilà
c'est extraordinaire ce qu'il fait mais
voilà c'est beaucoup de travail beaucoup
de c qu'il a mis dans l'entraînement
puis Gabriel AVN est-ce que c'est un
club qui qui peut permettre justement à
tous les jeunes de de progresser
rapidement et et de voilà tout
simplement prendre confiance en en soi
ce club son l'entraîneur et tous les
boxeurs qui sont peut peut mettre peut
donner toutes les toutes les armes en
main à n'importe qui pour y arriver mais
mais avant tout c'est c'est une
recherche personnelle si la personne
n'en veut pas je pense pas qu'elle en
voudra et après c'est comme dans tous
les dans tous les sports mais mais c'est
dans ce club là vraiment que si vous
voulez y arriver moi je vous conseille
d'aller la team for vraiment Marvin
petit tangy farouja quand il vous prend
sous son aile c'est c'est comment du
coup c'est c'est très dur des fois on
sait même plusù on est des fois on en a
envie de vomir des on le dit pas mais on
s'entraî dur mais il est toujours
derrière nous en train de crier il il
nous dit toujours c'est pas bien c'est
pas bien mais en fait c'est pour nous
aller auessus de ça quoi on comprend
depuis depuis le début d'entretien c'est
vraiment le travail qui qui prime dans
dans cette te
voilà on peut pas réussir sans
travailler voilà mais bon il a il y a le
côté cœur parce que Marvin petit ça
l'empêche pas de mettre les gants avec
Béatrice Mendy par exemple ou d'autres
enfants qui arrivent et il il aide la
personne à à progresser voilà bon pas
certaines périodes quand il prépare pas
de combat bien sûr mais il y a pas
quelqu'un qui est auudessus des autres
voilà un professionnel peut aider un
enfant aussi bien qu' un adulte et voilà
c'est une famille c'est vraiment une
famille on tend la main à la personne
qui arrive et est-ce que vous êtes plus
dur avec certains boxeurs par
exemple ça jeaurais pas le dire à la
télé
oui oui oui oui parce que il y en a il y
en a qui que je suis obligé de ralentir
c'est comme partout he chaque personne
est différente il y en a que comme
Gabriel que je suis obligé de ralentir
parce qu'il est tous les soirs à la
salle et il y a des fois il est en
surentraînement donc je ralentis et il y
a une autre il a il y a par exemple
Marvin qui est là et qu'il faut qu'il
faut prendre le fouet parce que il va en
mariage assez souvent
Marvin petit est-ce qu'il y a de la
pression quand on arrive dans cette team
farouja on sent une certaine pression
sur sur sur ces épaules quand quand on
arrive dans cette équipe c'est c'est une
grande pression quoi après faut faut la
stabiliser quoi faut faut s'entraîner
pour essayer de réussir mais pas pas
pour te dire je vais m'entraîner et je
fais ce que je veux quoi faut écouter le
le coach donc l'une des têtes d'affiche
de ce club c'est vous Marvin petit
quelles sont vos vos prochaines
échéances mais là de de récupérer la
sainture de de champion de France et
essayer de monter au titre européen quoi
si si on a une chance en on a une
proposition qu'on est en train d'étudier
qui est aller boxer en Australie au mois
de juin qui classerait
Marvin parmi les 10 meilleurs mondiaux
voilà et l'autre tête d'affiche donc ça
d Mad qui qui n'a pas pu venir ce soir
il va combattre prochainement pour le le
titre européen
ouis prochainement pour le titre
européen maintenant on n' pas le lieu ni
la malheureusement la
date on a plusieurs promoteurs qui sont
intéressés pour acheter le combat
maintenant on veut du concret on veut
des écrits parce que les paroles
s'envolent
et voilà donc le le le je pense qu'il va
être champion d'Europe et et j'espère
champion du monde j'espère champion du
monde dans
les dans les mois futurs donc quels sont
les objectifs tout simplement de de la
team farouja sur sur les prochaines
années
t moi je fais pas d'objectif parce que
on sait pas de quoi demain c'est fait
quelqu'un va devenir papa quelqu'un va
devenir malade
quelqu'un un autre espoir va arriver je
sais pas je fais pas d'objectif je fais
je vidé jour le
jour bon à savoir que bon c'est pas
notre boulot on est on a tous un boulot
à côté que ça soit Marvin ou ou Gabriel
qui est encore à l'école mais les Adila
il travaillent ils ont tous un boulot à
côté
et donc je fais pas d'objectif mais on
peut prétendre au titre mondial on peut
que ça soit Marvin que ça soit Adila et
d'autres tites national on peut le
prétendre maintenant il faut faut qu'on
nous aide voilà merci à tous les trois
d'être passés sur ce plateau on vous
souhaite bonne chance bonne chance à la
team farouja et on vous souhaite d'avoir
beaucoup de champions du monde dans les
années à venir merci beaucoup on passe
maintenant au
handball c'était l'événement handb de ce
weekend dans les la team 78 a organisé
samedi dimanche en tournoi au Palais des
sports d'élencour au gymnase malmedonne
de morpa et au gymnase montboron de
Versailles l'équipe a terminé à la 2uxe
place du tournoi résumé de ces deux
jours de compétition un reportage de
yolen Torz et de William
hell un grand tournoi de handball moins
de 18 ans étit organisé ce weekend dans
les gymnases d'élancour de morpa et de
Versailles h équipes de la région
Île-de-France ont fait le déplacement
pour participer à la compétition parmi
les favoris on retrouve Boulogne B
encour ponttoobo et team 78 l'équipe
locale le niveau est très relevé c'est
que des équipes qui qui vont qui jouent
le tableau en National c'est c'est bon
ils ont des bons joueurs il y en a il y
en a ils sont en C de formation il y en
a ils sont en équipe de France 4e de la
poule 4 du championnat de France
l'entraîneur de la team 78 veut avant
tout faire progresser son groupe pendant
ce tournoi face à de redoutables
adversaires à l'opposé d'accord tu à
l'opposé un gauche à droite s VI droite
ok que tu viens comme il vient là tu
viens là ok ensuite deème solution
deuxème solution ça sert à gagner
d'expérience à avoir des matchs durs à
apprendre à les gagner à apprendre à
rester motivé et concentré sur les
matchs qui sont touche touche comme on a
eu nous on gagne d'un match d'un but on
perd un autre match d'un but et l'autre
en fait il fallait qu'on gagne de 6 pour
gagner et on gagne pile de 6 donc
c'était commeétait un match parce qu'il
fallait avoir le bonus offensif après
une phase de poule convainquante et un
bilan de deux victoires en TR matchs la
team 78 se isse en finale l'équipe va
défier l'ogre crteil l'épouvantail du
tournoi un match compliqué que
l'entraîneur a préparé tactiquement tout
de suite commencer fort tout de suite
première attaque on l' construit après
on on enchaîne on défend et on joue
monté de balle repé défensif monter de
balle REP défensif engagement rapide
d'accord les gars fautir mettre du
rythme d'accord le discours d'Alexandre
taer a porté ses fruits dans le premier
acte la team 78 fait jeu égal avec
créteille l'équipe perd seulement de
deux buts à la mi-temps mais au retour
des vestiaires le rouleau compresseur
cret se met en marche score final
2519 on était fatigué on manquait de
rotation et puis au bout d'un moment
c'est l'échec sur les tirs du gardien
adverse qui a qui a donc remporté le
trophée du meilleur gardien qui nous a
fait mal notamment sur des sur des
contre-attaques les trois premiers
matchs ils ont été bons on a bien joué
on est
resté on est resté pareil sur tous les
matchs après celui-là on la première
mi-temps on accroche et la deuxième
mi-temps bah on décroche parce que
physiquement c'est plus compliqué c'est
une équipe qui sera sûrement championne
de France cette année qui a été l'année
dernière donc c'est un bon résultat
contre créteille pendant ces deux jours
de compétition la team 78 a pu montrer
sa combattivité une qualité qui sera
indispensable le 9 mai pour venir à bout
de trembler en 8e de finale du
championnat de France en attendant
l'équipe peut savourer sa très belle
deuxè place dans ce
tournoi la Ligue de tennis des yvelin
compte près de 45000 licenciés pour nous
par parler de cet engoumin que sucite la
petite balle jaune dans le département
nous recevons sur ce plateau Norbert
rampola le président de la ligue des
ivines bonsoir bonsoir Norbert ampola
alors qu'est-ce qui explique cette
passion pour le tennis dans lesines je
crois que ça date de de fort longtemps
puisque les Yveline dans les temps
glorieux en 86 avait plus de 71000
licenciers la profusion de de jeux
divers et variés que ce soit le le VTT
autres sport et voir sans parler d'ADS
de de PlayStation mais enfin disons
qu'effectivement le phénomène de société
la la Ligue a connu comme bon nombre
d'association sportive je dirais en
dehors du tennis une perte de de jeunes
et d'adultes et quels sont les clubs les
plus les plus performants dans le
département ah les plus performants vous
avez deux
clubs enfin on a 15 équipes en
championnat de
France h équipes messieurs se SEP
équipes dames le téiscope de plaisir
comme
a trois équipes en championnat de France
aussi maison la fite bien sûr qui a une
équipe en championnat de France et qui
se trouve comme plaisir dans le haut du
du du classement national au niveau des
championnats de France à national à donc
des clubs de de prestige on pas dire
puisque le Tennis Club de plaisir est en
championnat de France depuis
1983 il y a de nombreuses compétitions
aussi qui sont organisées dans les
Yvelines est-ce que le niveau est relevé
le niveau est relevé les jeunes aont
effectivement de bons parcours je dirais
régional voir nationale avec un jeune
comme Maxime peetel ou Joseph Guillin
Peel du Tennis Club de plaisir Maxime
Guillin lui étant du club de baahi qui
était champion du monde universitaire
c'est ça non pas champion du monde univ
non non non non c'est l'UNSS c'est pas
l'université c'est l'UNSS lycée où ils
ont gagné effectivement pour la 2èe
année consécutive avec le lycée Sonia de
lonet de Villepreux le championnat toute
académie l'année derre dernière et cette
année et ont participé au championnat du
monde à DOA au Qatar où ils ont obtenu
une place quand même assez honorable ils
auraient pu monter sur le podium de 5e
au classement des mondial est-ce que les
clubs ivilinois ont ont les moyens de de
faire progresser ces jeunes qui qui
peuvent devenir potentiellement des
champions B écoutez les moyens sont
donnés par les clubs pour faire
effectivement de futurs champions et la
Ligue a pour mission aussi si vous
voulez de les accompagner de les
entraîner de mettre à leur disposition
des entraînements pour qu'ils puissent
progresser dans leur parcours et
peut-être que demain on aura des
championnat de France on a pour Maxime
Peel pour le citer il est à la 119e
place mondiale aujourd'hui à ETF il
pourrait peut-être participer aux
qualifications du des Internationaux de
France junior en tout cas ils ont toutes
les clés en main pour pour progresser je
pense je pense l'actualité du tennis
c'est également r Garos donc nous sommes
à exactement à 21 jours des premiers
matchs de la la compétition cette année
il n'y aura pas
divlinois qualifié pour pour les
qualification peut-être d'un joueur ou
deux de maison la fit joueur numéro t
peut-être en en tableau final je pense
pas mais en qualification
vraisemblablement on peut y compter
autrement effectivement il n'y aura pas
de pur ivelinois puisque maison la fite
a quand même des joueurs si vous voulez
qui viennent un petit peu d'autres
structures pas forcément lesois et
est-ce que c'est une
déception oui et non c'est une déception
je crois que si vous voulez en ce qui
concerne les les meilleurs mondiaux ils
sont 128 à participer le tableau donc
228 et que il y a énormément de joueurs
qui voudrai accéder dans le monde et les
Français bien entendu à ces tournoi du
grand schlem et est-ce que le paradoxe
du tennis justement dans000 n'est pas là
il y a 45000
licenciés pas forcément de grands
champions enfin il y a des grands
champions mais pas forcément qualifiés
pour r Garo c'est ce qu'il est là le
paradoxe oui mais c'est pas tellement si
vous voulez la la vision c'est pas
tellement Roland Garos il y a un
parcours personnel professionnel aussi
le le grand chap comme je le dis c'est
quand même réservé à une grande élite du
tennis mondial mais les parcours quand
je vois si je prends à nouveau Maxime
Petel qui a gagné un tournoi de a ETF
grade 2 à Florence l'année précédente il
avait gagné aussi une finale à
Saint-Cyprien donc il y a des parcours
personnels qui existent effectivement je
crois la difficulté c'est aussi
peut-être que bon nombre de jeunes
privilégi aussi les études et le sport
en même temps car ce sont souvent dans
leur classique étude des locomotives et
qu'ils arrivent peut-être à faire les
deux de concert et ce qui est pas mal je
dirais on le sait Roland garot c'est un
tournoi qui est dominé depuis presque
une décennie par Raphaël Nadal est-ce
que vous pensez que le mallorquin peut
réaliser la décima c'est-à-dire son 10e
rang Garos cette année je crois qu'il
interpelle un petit peu son son match
perdu à Barcelone au 1er ou 2è tour je
crois euh 2e tour ne laisse pas présager
je crois qu'il est en réflexion mentale
assez importante pour lui et qu'il
pourrait se ressaisir parce qu'il
pourrait peut-être gagner pourquoi pas
son 10e tournoi de Roland Garros mais ça
écoutez l'avenir nous le dira c'est un
formidable champion oui tout à fait tout
à fait jokovic est un grand champion
fait desir montre encore je dirais des
grandes capacités et puis a aussi ed
Muray Andy Muray pardon qui aussi enfin
il y a une bonne une bonne dizaine de
joueurs mondiaux en tous les cas qui
sont à même figurer parmi les favoris de
Roland Garos si vous deviez miser une
petite pièce sur un joueur pour ce
Roland Garros Joko qui voudrait gagner
pour la première fois ran Garos et les
Français dans l'histoire il y a Gael
Monfils qui a réalisé une belle
demi-finale à Monte Carlo il y a
quelques jours oui et qui n'a pas été
très bon à c'est à bucar je crois euh
écoutez il est capable du meilleur comme
du pire entre guillemets si je peux me
permettre la chose il est capable de
faire un beau parcours gagner être en
finale à Roland Garros ça me semble un
peu difficile est-ce qu'un Français peut
peut réaliser l'exploit de gagner rol
Garou cette année je ne pense pas mais
on peut le souhaiter en tous les cas
tout bon supporterur de des Français on
l'espère en tous les cas un jour
peut-être C année pourquoi pas merci à
vous d'être venu sur ce plateau et bonne
chance bon une continuation pour cette
saison tennis qui commence justement et
qui se poursuit jusqu'à jusqu'à
septembre et même tout au long de
l'année on passe maintenant au résultats
du weekend dans le
département on commence cette page
rés on commence cette page résultat par
du football américain très mauvaise
opération pour les tempillers des
lancour les hommes d'Emmanuel charé ont
été corrigés à domicile par le flash de
la cour neuf ce samedi les allents
courtois se sont inclinés 37 à 6
conséquence au classement les Templiers
restent dans le ventrre mou de ce de
champion élite à la 6e place avec 15
points engrangé en 8 journées on écoute
le coach des footballeurs élan courtois
Emmanuel
Charet pour l'instant on est au milieu
du milieu de tableau avec notre début de
saison on mérite pas mieux donc voilà
pour l'instant on est milieu de tableau
et on espère qu'on va finir fort
enchaîner sur ces trois bons résultats
qu'on continue à capitaliser et à
continuer sur cette lancée donc là il
faut tout gagner jusqu'au bout pour être
sûr d'aller en play-off après on peut se
permettre une défaite sur les trois
derniers matchs
et après c'est despendard des autres par
contre donc euh voilà il vaut mieux être
confort et tout gagner prochain match
pour les tempillers desl en courours le
samedi 9 mai contre les Argonautes de
exenprence un match qui s'annonce
compliqué les provençons sont
actuellement à la 2uxe place du
classement en baseball montig bretonux
jouit son match en retard de la première
journée de 2e division mauvaise
opération pour les ivilinois l'équipe
des coupgardes de montigo broteneux
s'est incliné à domicile contre l'équipe
fédérale de Toulouse score final 8 à 6
en dimanche pour les Toulousains le
deuxième match programmé ce dimanche
après-midi a été interrompu par la pluie
en 2uxème Manche il sera rejoué dans les
prochaines semaines au classement montig
bretonux se retrouve à l'avant-dernière
place du classement de 2e division avec
quatre défaites en 6 matchs le
championnat est dominé par Toulouse qui
a remporté 4atre matchs sur quatre
depuis le début de la saison il y avait
également de la boxe éducative ce
weekend Jordan dwick du Boxing Club de
la verrière en rouge sur la photo est
devenu champion de France minime des
moins de 76 kg à la pom ré prédanger il
obtient la médaille d'or dès sa première
saison de boxe anglaise le Boxing Club
de laavrière a également réalisé une
bonne performance dans la catégorie
moins de 51 kg Théo Dominguez en bleu
sur la photo a remporté la médaille de
bronze après avoir perdu en demi-finale
en rugby la finale du championnat
île-de-fance senior a été programmé ce
dimanche à Montmorency Chevreuse qui
vient tout juste de terminer premier de
sa poule de division d'honneur été
qualifié pour ce grand rendez-vous
régional mais les chevretins se sont
incliner de Just de justesse contre
Sergi Pontois sur le score de 16 à 13 la
défense de Chevreuse a craqué dans les
derniers instants de la partie Chevreuse
va maintenant s'attaquer au championnat
de France la compétition est programmée
au mois de mai et puis trois rendez-vous
sportifs à ne pas manquer ce weekend
premier match à noter dans vos agendas
Trapp le PEC en football la rencontre
est programmée ce dimanche à 15h30 au
stade de Gilbert chansac à trappe les
joueurs de mochchan aousi sont dans une
bonne dynamique ils viennent d'enchaîner
trois matchs consécutifs sans défaite
conséquence les traapistes remonte
doucement en classement et peuvent viser
le podium en cette fin de saison le
match contre l'OPEC paraît très
équilibré sur le pap les deux équipes se
sont séparées que ne sont séparées que
par un point en classement trappe compte
sur le soutien du public pour emporter
la victoire il y aura du tennis
également ce weekend l'Open de tennis
dlancour s'achève ce samedi avec les
finales dames et les finales hommes ce
samedi au Parc des Sports gu Boniface ce
tournoi rassemblé va rassembler une
centaine de participants de niveau
professionnel et non classés sur le
cours Suzanne anglen la remise de
récompense est programmée samedi à
partir de 17h enfin il y aura du
cyclisme ce vendredi avec la course Bois
d'Arcy basinville le départ sera donné
depuis la mairie de boisarciy à 8h du
matin le peleton traversera ensuite la
vallée de chevos pour rejoindre
basinville au total les clistes vont
pédaler pendant 101 km près de 500
coureurs de la région Île-de-France vont
participer à la compétition c'est la fin
de ce 78 sport merci d'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve lundi prochain pour un
prochain magazine très bonne soirée sur
TVfil